[Music]
from visionary director Tim Burton I
mean from writer Tim Burton with music
and lyrics by Tim Burton no well what
did he do Tim Burton's The Nightmare
Before Christmas suit up for a
heartwarming holiday classic full of
incredible animation amazing songs and
haunting visuals that makes every emo
kid feel special and unique even though
they're all in love with the same movie
ah journey to a magical forest where
inside each tree lies a world dedicated
to a single holiday except for all the
Jewish ones and discover Halloweentown
a land that exists just to throw one
party a year and the rest of the time
rehearses is their big dance number I
guess meet Jack the pumpkin King a
manorexic skeleton when he tires of his
life of fame and fortune he'll set off
on a grand adventure of cultural
appropriation but you're the pumpkin
King not anymore
as he hijacks Christmas traumatizes
children
and lets a demon have his way with Santa
Claus what are you going to do go to do
the best I can yeah see this is what
happens when you take Jesus at a
Christmas experience a whimsical
one-sided romance between Jack and your
first goth crush Sally a suicidal cutter
who can't stop roofing or dad that's
twice this month you slipped deadly
nightshade into my tea and run off three
times
sheíll pine to jump jacks bones even
though he never listens to a word she
says
until they randomly fall in love and
live happily ever after the end
seriously the movies like an hour long
there's really not that much to it so
enjoy this short but sweet film that
launched an entire genre of creepy
stop-motion kids movies that we mostly
remember for it's gorgeous score and
catchy music with unforgettable songs
like the is this a Halloween or
Christmas movie Saw
[Music]
is it Christmas or is it Halloween it's
mixed take one look at this see see the
streets are lined with toys and happy
children but I look like imma kill them
how can two things so divergent coexist
screw this
and the perennial classic that we keep
hot topic in business aww
[Music]
[Applause]
storing
slenderman helena cotton carter a
two-faced politician oh i see what you
did there
duck man remembered up man roo dog the
dead Nosed Reindeer and evil laundry a
christmas story that c was terrifying
but at least we know from the black
lights that there's no DNA on Santa I've
got to stop watching SVU be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers hey
screen junkies need more horror then
click the box on the left and enjoy the
return of knocking dead
where he breakdown every episode from
The Walking Dead live on Mondays at 1
p.m. and to start things off with a bang
we have Robert Kirkman coming in to take
your questions on this week's a rendus
murder if that's too dark for you why
not click the Box on the right to watch
the Roast of Rick Grimes it's got stuff
and thangs now for something truly
spooky the comments turn the comments
for Ghost Busters on honest trailers
hates comments now disabling comments I
think I get what you did it but I don't
like that turn the comments on turn the
comments on you cowards open the
comments on Ghost Busters 2016 new Cox
pretty cowardly to disable comments for
the coast Buster's on his trailer that
being said it was a very well done video